if you've ever played the Super Nintendo
classic Super Mario World you've seen it
as Yoshi and Mario gallivant through
each level yo she pulls a Miley Cyrus
circa 2015 to grab certain items with
his tongue at Mario's command while some
players argue that their favorite
mustachioed plumber was simply pointing
at what he wanted Yoshi to slurp up
others had a more sinister suggestion
Mario was actually punching Yoshi in the
head believe it or not we've since
discovered that team head punch was
absolutely right in an interview on
Nintendo's official site in September
2017 Super Mario World developers to
Kashi 2 Zucca and CID Geoff Umi he no
discussed how the character of Yoshi
evolved including his much buzzed-about
tongue animation he no said lots of
people think that while Mario is
pointing his finger forward he's saying
go and yoshi's tongue comes out however
the setup that I drew was that when
Mario punches Yoshi in the head the
character's tongue shoots out in
surprise but the developers didn't want
gamers to think Mario was mean so the
official explanation became that Mario
was merely gesturing at what he wanted
his Dino pal to retrieve official game
art was drawn up to reflect this as well
but there was no change to the actual
animation in the game which was low-res
enough to obscure the Yoshi abuse keno
also said there used to be a Bop sound
to accompany the punch but quote it
seemed like people would say poor Yoshi
so they changed it to this sound which
he no says is supposed to represent
Mario saying go so now you know the
in-game animation was indeed intended to
depict Mario punching his trusty Dino
steed into submission but Nintendo
covered up the mistreatment with a
sweeter sound effect and some very
effective propaganda thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
you
[Music]